hey what's up guys this is marcus
brownlee from mkbhd and welcome to
another hd video this was going to be a
hardware video about the actual uh the
stand i'm using right now you may or may
not have noticed it it is quite a bit
different than my old stand which was
the nzxt cryo lx i did do an unboxing
video of that check it out this is from
handstands.com and uh right now at the
moment i do not have a tripod so you're
gonna have to excuse the shaky camera
work here so uh first of all here we go
so first of all there's a little
branding on the front it does say this
is the i desk
all right um
there's not a whole lot that is
ridiculously unique about this although
it does have a couple of very nice
features so i'm just going to do a
rundown with you guys because i know
you've probably been waiting for this so
here we go first of all if we go over to
the side here you can see that this does
raise your desk raise your laptop off
the ground you get a nice little typing
angle here if you do like typing like
that but i do suggest an external
keyboard because this is as low as it
will go
this is a 17 inch laptop so there's a
little bit of an overhang if i pick up
the camera once again i apologize i
don't have a tripod yet but there's a
little bit of an overhang
um the cool thing about this is i think
the best feature about this is that it
has a usb hub in the back this is a four
port usb hub 2.0 and powered um if we
swing around to the other side
if we swing around to the other side you
can see there's that little light right
there letting us know that it is powered
a green and a red light
i do have a lot of cords going back here
because i have my ipod cable i have my
phone adapter i have a whole lot of
cables going on the uh but i did use the
mzxd cryo lx and that was managed quite
fine
another cool feature about this um is
pretty much the uh the whole adjustable
feature so i'm going to change the
camera angle so you guys can see exactly
how to adjust the stand height
okay so adjusting the stand is really
easy there's a knob down here in the
bottom and actually there's a little
cord in the way but you can see that
knob right there that knob is what we
use to pull outward and then tilt the
stand up now the stand has six uh
vertical positions so it does go up up
up six times until it goes all the way
almost completely vertical um and your
laptop will obviously be your screen
will be way far off the ground uh but
that is a cool feature that you can
change uh the laptop the height and this
is you know a sturdy plastic you can see
this uh this fan this base right here
that is made of plastic but it is very
sturdy plastic so i do like the build
it's very good material so i'm just
going to go back to a head-on view of
this uh stand
okay so we're back to the front here and
i just got to point out a few other
things the first part is you do have a
little lip on the front here now you may
or may not have noticed already this
does block the touch pad so if you if
you don't have an external mouse like
that or you don't have a pull out
keyboard
down here then you're going to have
problems because you won't be able to uh
use the click wheel or the click buttons
that are actually there's me
underneath the uh the cleat the keyboard
so do know that there's a lip which is
it is used for uh sturdying your laptop
and it's not going to go anywhere there
are foam pads underneath here
so you're not your laptop's not
scratched but um there's this one thing
about this hp pavilion is that number
one the fingerprint reader is right here
and number two the microphone and two
headphone jacks are right under that lip
so it is a little bit of an
inconvenience for people who have an hp
laptop
but overall this laptop i think it's
quite nice i'm not the laptop the uh
the case or the stand from
handstands.com again link in the
description check it out very very nice
products offered at this company's
website you should definitely go check
this out but uh this case again i like i
said is available for 39.99 i keep
saying case this is a stand available
for forty dollars at hampsteams.com and
i basically it is a very cool case if
you're looking to get something uh to
improve your typing angle or if you're
not planning on typing an angle like
this then you can have your laptop
monitor actually way uh off the ground
quite a bit so if i put this back here
uh that's basically all i have to say
this is uh you know it's very convenient
the usb hub is obviously quite nice i'm
i'm glad it has the usb hub and the
thing is i didn't even mention
it's detachable yes the usb hub is
detachable so you'll be able to remove
it from the back and you get a little
bit more mobility and that also is cool
because there's only one cable
connecting you to the usb hub so all you
have to do if you want to go mobile is
just unplug that one usb cord and you're
completely free to go
so this has been marcus brownlee from
mkbhd thank you for watching this
hardware video again the link to the
company is in the description and uh
keep watching these videos subscribe if
you like it and thanks for watching
peace